Bruce came up with this whole idea about
the Planet Hollywood you know he want to
compete with the Hard Rock
that was a great idea wasn't it
so so anyway he came with this old
gimmick about plan a Planet Hollywood
that he'd want all this sub Hollywood
friends to invest in this it's weird new
venture and stuff like that he got all
his friends Sylvester Stallone you know
all this other guys that used to be like
him and so so either way they put in
hundreds of thousand dollars I put in a
lot of damn money but it's amazing Bruce
you owe me more money than my
family can I mean that
I'm not here to roast you I'm here to
collect honey
[Music]